Babies with beards and cups of warm kitty.
Take it easy, because we are about to loose
control.
It's episode 49 of IMG!
Okay, whose legs are whose?
And can you find the hidden scary face?
If Pac-Man has a skull, it probably looks
like this.
And Information Is Beautiful analyzed horoscopes
to create a visualization of the most commonly
used words by sign.
Words in red were uniquely common for each
sign.
The Earth orbits on a tilt, so as the year
progresses, the terminator, the line marking
the border between night and day sways back
and forth.
These pictures were all taken at 6 a.m. from
September 2010 to September 2011, giving us
an incredible time lapse of day and night
on Earth for one year.
Makes you a bit dizzy?
Well, just be sure you don't puke ribbons.
Oh, a facelifting cream.
Ooops.
The lines on a parking lot can be dandelions
and Craig Alan painted these portraits of
famous faces, made out of people standing around.
Here's a cat... but where does it end?
Oookay.
This cat isn't as big, but the mess he made is.
And Kerry Skarbakka uses rock climbing equipment,
safe landing mats or sometimes nothing to
make these photos of himself falling.
Seth Casteel captures dogs falling into water.
And Robert Downey Jr. as a pin-up girl is
something fun to gawk at.
Though you can also gawk at Michelangelo's
Sistine Chapel by using the Vatican's amazing
virtual tour.
It's almost more of a DONG than an IMG, but
go ahead, look around with the mouse and zoom
in and out by scrolling.
The art is amazing, but let's be honest.
All paintings are better with cats added.
Now this hurts my brain.
Moving dots, whose meaning is ambiguous, we
can add cues that make it look like a spinning
helix or enable a different cue that turns
it into a waving ribbon.
Still crazier, a cue that turns your perception
of the whole thing into a chain of flat moving bulges.
I love these photographs of people whose arms
melt into the horizon.
Oh, and this roller-coaster?
It's actually a walking coaster.
The loop, though, is pretty much impossible to travel.
I Love Graphs showed off a sweet chocolate
chart and Palindrome.
Get it?
On Facebook.com/VsauceGaming you guys have
been awesome.
Manuel points out a can't-unsee-fact about
the ampersand.
Ashley showed us a grandfather clock with
an attitude.
And Garett suggested a clever Easter prank.
Oh and Shelby said "Ladies..."
Here's an artist who draws shoes turning into
umbrellas and has also built super-cool squashed-bug
wallpaper, tables that collide, do backflips
and play Twister.
Yayoi Kusama put a blank white room in a museum
and then gave stickers to kids, who could
place them anywhere.
It was fun.
And after long enough, it got pretty gosh darn
awesome.
So is the room of heights, where
visitors were asked to measure and mark their
own height on a wall, eventually leaving a
thick human-height-sized band across the room.
Too analytical?
Well how about we just get a giant helium
balloon covered in charcoal spikes.
Batting it around draws on the walls.
If your car gets stuck you might need camel
to...wing.
And this week, 9Gag showed me that tortoise
still has a few tricks up his shell.
Ned Hardy displayed Star Wars if Doctor Seuss
had written it.
And Cecilia Paredes paints herself to hide,
just like Bolin, except she often leaves her
hair and eyes strikingly visible.
I leave you with a mystery.
An optical illusion consisting of moving dots
and circles, but what's crazy is that we,
to this day, do not know why our brains add
this illusory contour connecting the dots.
There's no known mechanism or theory yet proposed
to explain what we see.
If you figure it out, you should probably
let science know, but until then...
As always, thanks for watching.